you this morning the coronavirus
pandemic has left at least
1500 public school students staff
and teachers quarantined in at least
eight states
in a new report the american academy of
pediatrics recommends masks for
all kids two and older at school and in
public spaces
it also warns that asymptomatic children
who test
positive should be isolated for up to 14
days
to avoid spreading the virus our lead
national correspondent david begno's in
miami beach
david good morning anthony good morning
nearly all of the school districts here
in the state of florida
are being ordered by state leaders to
offer some kind of in-person learning
meanwhile the state's largest teachers
union is suing over
that saying it's not a good idea because
the virus is simply too widespread in
this state
that continues to be a hot spot for the
country
meanwhile parents at this very moment
are trying to make what they think is
the best decision
for their kid about whether they should
actually go into the classroom
i'm semi nervous but i feel like
the school's going to do everything to
keep the kids safe
this is rebecca evans she says she's
comfortable that her 14 year old
daughter will start
classes at palmetto high school near
sarasota florida on monday
that's even though some staff members
are already in quarantine because
there's already been a positive covet 19
case on campus
it happened while teachers were there
getting ready for the start of the year
so you think she is making the right
decision i feel like
we need a little bit of normalcy she
needs that
and she made the decision and hopefully
it's the right one
but as the state moves ahead with
in-person learning some educators are
worried that things are moving a little
too fast
educators like catalina bested she's a
spanish teacher at tampa bay technical
high school
she is also a coronavirus survivor i
literally felt myself
knocking on death's doorway i cannot
imagine
a lot of my older co-workers possibly
even surviving this
in 34 states and puerto rico the percent
of coronavirus tests coming back
positive
is still higher than the recommended
level for reopening
we have a lot of infection going on do
you really want to put the kids back in
school
in an interview thursday dr anthony
fauci gave a blunt assessment
of our nation's coronavirus response
bottom line
is i'm not pleased with how things are
going
as the pandemic moves across the country
out of control
it continues to tear apart families like
charlie vallejos
never in my wildest dreams would i ever
thought and that my grandfather would
have passed from kovit let alone my
father
charlie's father and grandfather doctors
carlos
and george vallejo were both
hospitalized with coronavirus on
father's day
they died just weeks apart both men were
respected community leaders
in the hialeah neighborhood a suburb of
miami
89 year old george was long retired but
57 year old carlos was treating covet
patients right before he contracted the
virus
charlie says they leave behind a legacy
of helping others
they were my inspiration for studying
medicine my father wasn't is my hero
he died on the front lines doing what he
believed was right
the vallejos are a family of doctors
there are 20 of them
that either practice some type of
medicine dentistry or psychiatry
one vallejo who doesn't is actually a
reporter she works with us here at the
cbs station in miami
her name is jessica vallejo our
sincerest condolences to the family
vlad one more thing before we go since
the pandemic started
estimates are at least 1 000 frontline
healthcare workers have died
because of covet 19.
david that is a stunning statistic thank
you so much for your reporting we really
appreciate